dell has just updated their XPS 13
laptop so we figured we'd compare it to
a closely priced MacBook Pro but
unfortunately for the second year in row
Apple has left the lower end 13-inch
model completely untouched still packing
an old dual-core processor and this is
really disappointing since the XPS packs
a quad-core processor and the MacBook
Pro is quite a bit more expensive for a
similarly spec model so we know that the
Dell is going to be a faster machine for
a cheaper price but what if the MacBook
Pro will still give you a better overall
experience despite those downsides so
much so that it'll actually be worth
spending the extra cash on it for
instance the biggest factor in making
this decision is whether you like
Windows or Mac OS better some people
can't stand Windows so they'll gladly
pay the extra cash for a Mac but for
those who don't really mind either one
let's get started
last year's XPS 13 featured Windows
hello which automatically logged you in
to your laptop by using cameras to
recognize your face it was great but it
required the cameras to sit below the
display well this year that feature is
gone so the webcam goes back up above
the display without affecting the top
bezel much at all the MacBook Pro
clearly has larger bezels that we wish
Apple would slim down already but it
still looks okay overall technically
both displays are thirteen point three
inches large but it turns out to the
MacBook Pros display actually has around
four square inches more screen space due
to using a 16 by 10 aspect ratio instead
of sixteen by nine which is great for
watching full screen sixteen by nine
videos but the downside is that you
don't get as much vertical space while
browsing the web which is a huge
positive for the MacBook not only that
but the MacBook Pro gets a 2.5 k
resolution display compared to this XPS
which is packin 1080p and the difference
is easily noticeable the XPS also has a
4k version but it's a few hundred
dollars more expensive and more
comparable to the touch bar MacBook Pro
we also tested screen brightness and the
MacBook Pro definitely gets a lot
brighter which is really nice for using
in bright rooms or outside and it's also
much more color accurate with p-3 wide
color gamut support as for the design
itself the MacBook shell is machined out
of a solid block of aluminum so it feels
great the XPS on the other hand uses a
lot of plastic sandwiched between an
aluminum case so it's also quite a bit
thicker than the MacBook Pro at its
thickest point but slightly thinner at
the thinnest point and when you stack
them on top of each other it's also
quite a bit smaller for ports the xbs
features three Gen 2 USB C ports with
two of them supporting Thunderbolt 3
alongside a headphone jack in a mini SD
card slot the MacBook is limited to just
two Thunderbolt reports in a headphone
jack so the XPS one's there
they both use USB C for charging but the
XPS a charging cable is built into the
power brick so you can't disconnect it
and use it for data transfer like you
can on the MacBook Pro just like last
year the xB s is a bit tough to open up
since it lacks a notch in the front and
the hinge has a lot of resistance while
the MacBook Pro easily opens out with
just one finger the XPS is power button
doubles as a fingerprint reader so you
can conveniently login without typing in
the password like you have to do on the
MacBook and the keyboard feels pretty
great with a lot of key travel the
MacBook Pro skis are very clicky which I
personally prefer but it's definitely
not as comfortable to type on with the
slow key travel and perhaps the biggest
downside for the MacBook is that it's
using the failure-prone butterfly
keyboard that's been causing Apple a lot
of issues in recent years now for the
track pads the MacBook Pro has the best
trackpad out of any laptop ever and I'm
not exaggerating it doesn't actually
move or click it uses forced touch
technology to simulate clicks using
haptic feedback so it's extremely
reliable and you get an even clicking
field all around and you can even
customize the force it takes to register
a click in the settings the XPS is
trackpad is much smaller so you don't
get as much room to move around and it
requires a lot more pressure to click
the higher you get on the trackpad
however it's pretty decent compared to
other Windows laptops for the webcams
both don't look very great at all with
the MacBook having a lot of visible
noise which the XPS gets rid of using
some heavy noise reduction but it also
adds quite a lot of saturation making
skin look a bit orange this is a
microphone quality test on the MacBook
Pro this is a microphone quality tests
on the Dell XPS 13 but as you just heard
in that clip the microphone quality on
the Dell is horrible compared to the
MacBook and before we get into
performance let's compare the speaker
quality
[Music]
[Music]
as you've just heard the MacBook Pro
blows the XPS s speakers out of the
water there really is no comparison in
everything from volume to dynamic range
and just overall sound quality in
general so far the MacBook Pro is
looking like the champ and overall user
experience from the design build quality
trackpad speakers and display quality
even despite the subpar keyboard
however the XPS packs a quad-core
processor while the MacBook only gets
two cores so let's get into performance
starting with Geekbench fours multi-core
tests for some reason the dell is
scoring barely any faster than the
MacBook which isn't right at all it
turns out that you have to click the
battery icon in the system tray and
switch the battery saving slider to Best
Performance and you also have to plug in
the power cable to unlock the rest of
the power now we're getting a much
higher score that completely destroys
the MacBook Pro but we're also gonna see
less battery life than what Dell rated
at we saw similar results and the more
realistic Cinebench r15 benchmark where
we got almost a hundred more points by
plugging it into power and using best
performance mode but either way the XPS
outperforms a MacBook Pro by a massive
margin and in Geekbench for its graphics
test the XPS is once again scoring
better than the MacBook Pro so we're
really impressed with its performance
but on a positive note the MacBook Pros
SSD storage is quite a bit faster than
the Dells which is useful for everything
from transferring data to opening apps
but the Dell is a clear winner in
overall performance so if you're using
professional apps that can use all that
power you should definitely choose the
Dell but if you just need a laptop to do
basic things like browse the internet
use web-based apps and basic stuff like
that the MacBook Pro will be more than
powerful enough but then again if you're
not using professional apps you really
don't need the MacBook Pro the better
option is the 2018 MacBook Air it's got
newer technology with the t2 chip
fingerprint reader a more comfortable
keyboard better battery life in a better
price so in this case who is the 2017
MacBook Pro for well it's for those who
are using professional apps that are
exclusive to Mac OS but even in this
case
I would seriously recommend just paying
$1,800 for the 2019 MacBook Pro which
just came out last month and has a
quad-core processor this video is
sponsored by PDF Elements 7 which allows
you to create edit convert and much more
on both Windows and Mac PDF Elements 7
has a very simple word like interface so
anyone can easily use it but it's packed
with powerful features like commenting
watermarking batch processing securing
and more it can even transform image
based PDFs into selectable searchable
and editable text it's a great
alternative to Adobe Acrobat at a much
lower price and if you use our link in
the video description you can get 50%
off the normal price so check it out
today if you need help choosing a laptop
for your needs leave a comment below and
we'll help you out if you like this
comparison tap the like button and click
the circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]